皆さんこんにちはどう件です
今日は
僕にとってものすごく嬉しい日です
それは何でかっていて
今日
これをもらったからです
これはどういうものかっていうとう
車の鍵じゃなくて
日本による僕のマンソンの鍵です
不思議な感じがするねー
別に現金とか使って買ったわけじゃないんで
あれなんですけれども普通に35年のローン今組んでいますが
まさかへ
何だろう本当にちっちゃい時からいつかは日本に住みたいなと思っていて
ねえそのん
理想の中で
高
日本に住んすぐ化けじゃなくてね日本にあるマンションの比較的にいいいい部屋
変えたらなってほんとほんとに10歳ぐらいの時からずっと思ってきたんで
やっとそれが
手に手に入ったっていうのはなんか今今でも実感してないんです
ガーまあとりあえずへ
皆さんの支援があっての購入ですので
今まで
支援応援してくださった皆さんにへ
お礼を言いたくてこの動画を作ることにしました
今まで本当に
ありがとうございます
ここの心から感謝しています
これはマジです
今後ともよろしくお願いします
皆さんがやっている
僕はう服ちょっと苦手なんですけれども
なんか vanson ツアー
見たいの動画を作ってみようかなと今思っていますでそれなんで買っていってなん
だろう
だいたいそのヘアツアーとかまぁいう感じのん動画ってだいたい
何だろうパートだと思うんですよねねしかも東京っていうことは圧倒的に多いと思うん
で
今回は a 例えば日本日本の田舎の
マンション
だったらどんなのかっていうのを
紹介したいなと思って
はいまあ作ろうと思っています
でまぁ今度引っ越すんでえ
あと1週間ぐらい飛行しますのでその時に
ちょっと作ってみますはい
あと何だろうポンッ
家を買うっていうのはものすごくなんだろう
アパートを借りると全然違うかなと思いますので
なんだろいつかは日本に住みたいとかええええ
じゃなくていつか日本で家を買いたいとか
家を買うっていうのは日本だったらどういう流れ
ただ思っている人はいるかなと思いますので
まあそういった系の質問も
いただけたらなぁと思っていますねまぁいくつかの動画を
何だろうマンションシリーズみたいな
a 動画をいくつか
を出せたらなと思っています
b かなぁ
えっとほんとこういう脚本がない道が一番苦手なんだよね
はい以上です今まで本当にありがとうございます本当心から感謝しています今後とも
よろしくお願いします